good morning believe nation today's
message is over to you Morgan Freeman to
collect unemployment you have to go out
and hunt for employment they give you
have a code and mine was as a clerk
typist so you karate look for work as a
clerk typist in one day I just I can't
keep being forced to be a clerk typist
so I went to the employment office and I
asked to see the supervisor and I was
led into this office in this pretty
little native redhead whose name was
mrs. Lipton what can I do for you I said
you're forcing me to be something I'm
not I have to go out and look for work
as a clerk typist I'm not a clerk typist
I'm an actor so I just can't keep doing
it this way it took this thing and
stamped my employment book said you get
six months go be an actor so if mrs.
Lipton is alive today
this is Lipton I'm an actor so I think
all of us as entrepreneurs have had
people along our path who have thought
and told us that we need to be someone
else than who we are and they tell us
that you shouldn't be an entrepreneur
you should go back to school you should
be an accountant you should be a lawyer
or whatever profession and nothing
against those professions but if that's
not who you are then that's not where
you should be going and you need to
stand up for yourself you need to let
the world know that I do not want to be
an accountant I want to be whatever and
not blaming them and not complaining
about them and standing up for yourself
and when you take responsibility for
your life things start to change
the harder part though is understanding
that you don't need their approval that
you don't need to convince them that all
you need to do is accept yourself
imagine what would have happened to
Morgan Freedman if he went into that
office and mrs. Lipton said no right he
was fortunate that she said yes that he
got to six months and became an actor
but imagine if she said no what would he
have done
imagine if he then felt defeated and
agreed with her assessment and then
continued on his hunt to be a typist a
career that he hated and that with years
and years and years and years they
passed on he would hate more more and
more
and he would wake up and drop the job
that he just couldn't stay in doing
imagine if he followed that path how
much he would have missed out and also
the world would have missed out by him
being such a great actor we're on the
other hand imagine if she said no and he
said I don't need your acceptance and he
took the harder road of not being able
to collect his unemployment cheques but
went off to pursue his passion of being
an actor and how much more satisfied and
how much more fulfilled his life would
be that's the harder part when the
people around you who can control a
little bit of your life who have some
strings to be able to pull they don't
approve of the decisions that you're
making understanding that you don't need
their approval that you will find
another way that their acceptance of you
is not the only path to you achieving
your goals and the answer isn't to bow
down and accept their limited view of
the world and what you should become and
instead to rebel against it and become
the best version of yourself so the
question today today is I'm curious what
you had to overcome in your path to be
an entrepreneur who was someone who is
limiting you know the thoughts of you of
where you could go and said that you
couldn't do it and what happened did you
change their mind or did you just move
past it yourself and said I'm gonna
achieve success without them I think
it's a deeper question by thinking by
sharing the answer could really help
other people who are watches video and
reading the comments so please share
your story leaving the comment
below finally want to give a quick
shoutout to Scott from Scott Brendan
Hoffman comm Scott thank you so much for
buying a copy of my book it really means
a lot to me for those of you watching if
you want your chance at eyeshadow in a
future video make sure to pick up a copy
of the book and then email in your
receipt so we can keep track thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso